Carroll is with us in New Jersey hey
Carol your question for Christian baby
hey
so my question is I'm currently working
on baby step number two and me and my
husband have about 30,000 left and a
summer guys too long we have some IRS
debt and we have some credit cards how
much do you know how much you owe on
your student loans about eighteen
thousand how much on credit cards I want
to say maybe seven thousand and how much
to the KGB I mean the IRS that I think
three thousand okay all right and what's
your household income so after taxes we
make about 80,000 80,000 after taxes yes
okay oh yes so my question is we also
have a lease for one car that's the only
car that we had in the house and though
uses it up in March so we have to start
figuring out what we're going to do
after that I've been working from home
because of the ground buyers and he
works five minutes away and he's been
able to use the car at his job but he
wants to start looking into financing a
car for each of us one son races up
because I'll be going back to work in
January so I was wondering what you
think we should do okay and how did you
find us
how did I find a Brandi
well my church does a few and I've heard
about you guys for years but I started
doing some antique myself in beginning
of me okay so then you know what we
would tell you yeah but I mean I figured
what you would tell me it's just I'm
having a hard time convincing my husband
of that oh okay that's a different
equation alright so you went to the
financial peace class at your church and
he didn't go I know I've been doing it
by myself at home yeah okay why is he
not participating with you he said that
he's been very busy at work
and he doesn't have much time to do it
right now he wants to do it eventually
but right now is me yeah but he watched
every episode of Tiger King didn't he
not Tiger king but he watches some other
stuff okay so what we really got is that
you've discovered some new information
and you haven't been able to get him to
look at that information with you why is
that really I'm not sure he I've been
telling him everything that I've learned
and he he just said it's like for
example with the car he likes the perks
of having a new car with newer
technology and I'm having to deal with
any issues if it comes up yeah which is
all which is all a bunch of crap you've
got issues they're just they might not
be car issues but you're gonna have
issues in a different area you know what
I mean yeah with the with the bills with
the debt so it's sometimes we have this
idea that I'm gonna choose this path
because it's easier it's better for me
but we're creating problems in another
area by making those decisions so I just
want to look at this objectively to say
you know not not buy into that myth that
that's relieving you of your issues it's
just me tell you how ridiculous the
situation looks okay the guy with a
$3,000 IRS lien is making the financial
decisions does that not sound stupid to
you it sounds stupid to me so I really
think that he first needs to recognize
that the way you all have been handling
money sucks you're deeply in debt and
you owe the IRS and so the last thing
you need to do is to go further in a
debt now how to get him to do that well
I think that comes down to for some
reason he doesn't value your opinion
because I can tell you if my wife sits
down in front of me and says this is a
big deal we
got to talk about this I want us to
address this I've got a problem with
this whatever the this is a once she
presents it like that now she doesn't
drive by and just goes I got about about
iron keeps walking that's another thing
but she sits down and we look at each
other after 38 years of marriage and she
looks at me and she says this matters
when you sit down with Matt and say Matt
this matters then Matt goes yeah but I
think I'm gonna go buy some cars that
ain't happening
no and what's interesting is I think
it's really important and this is a good
call-out for Carol because maybe she has
been doing a drive-by and opportunities
to sit down and I will do that on
certain things I'll sit and say Matt
this is important to me whatever this is
whatever were talking my decision a trip
something with kids Matt this is really
important to stop everything turn off
all the stupid yes zingers and dinners
that are gone in the house kids are in
bed look into my eyes out of a 10 this
is a 10 yes when you set that stage
everything that follows carries a
different weight now don't use it all
the time I use it when it's really
something big and important we've got to
be on the same page and what's
interesting it changes the whole tone of
the conversation he he literally he
leans in he looks at me we make the
decision differently together because we
talked we stressed how important it is
and I think Carol if you do that and
he's still not paying attention that's
it that's a bigger problem yeah but the
problem is that's the marriage problem
and the the 10 here is not the cars the
10 is you guys have horribly handled
your finances for an extended period of
time
you need to stop it well it's the Dave
Ramsey stuff or not yeah and so you need
to lean in and go the stuff I've been
learning in this online class is
Financial Peace University is rocking my
world and you have got to look at this
with me I'm not gonna be okay with you
being current on Netflix and not looking
at this with me this matters now I will
tell you this Carol Sharon and I have
discovered this communication issue that
guys including this guy right here do
not hear you if you expect us to read
your freaking mind and we do not hear
you if you just kind of
just gently goodnight baby hey man keep
walking drop tense but I dropped him
I don't need hints I need a tuba for
between the eyes you have to hit me over
the head with a large board and then I
hear you yeah but I mean you cannot the
subtlety of communication doesn't work
with most guys no you got to get us you
got to really get our so that's why sigh
turn off all the ringy-dingy take his
hands and yours and look at me this is
not gonna go well if you don't hear me
on this because I'm becoming
increasingly terrified of how we suck at
handling money and you have got to look
at this class with me and we've got to
discuss it together it's rocking my
world you've got to look at this with me
and that's different then oh this is a
good book I read you might want to try
it that is a whole different
conversation yeah and sharing does that
she's got you know she read the wove
this wave this fiction book around under
my nose for about six months and you
know finally she got her feelings hurt
that I didn't read the stupid thing but
she never did really go
really I'll ask Matt when Matt Matt is
not in a hurry for anything he is steady
and patient I am just urgent I'm like
Rachel we're just so urgent and so I'll
ask him something and he'll say yeah
yeah yeah and I'll say okay wit win went
just just so I have some expectation
next week no I just want to know it's
cool I'm cool with whatever but it helps
him think of like okay I really am gonna
do this he does that with me too like
hey I need you to do XYZ when are you
gonna oh okay I'll do it next Thursday
you know if you actually put a time to
it it's more likely to happen if you
just say yes you can say yes for six
years and you've never looked at it so
we'll put it on you that maybe you've
been too subtle but if he hears from his
wife that this is an eight or a ten on a
scale of ten of importance to you and
then he totally ignores your freaking
opinion you don't have a financial
problem you have a marriage problems yes
and you need to sit down with your
pastor and begin marriage counseling
because in that's true of husbands and
wives that's right you need to be able
to hear each other respect each other's
opinion and then argue it out sometimes
Sharon has a real strong opinion she
just
you know and not usually but but she
does have that you know it comes up it
could happen once in 38 years so and she
just and you know so but you at least
got to get real clear communication on
the level of importance because I think
this is becoming an eight or a ten to
you and it's a point five to him nine
minutes radar not even showing up not
even going bleep leap leap
nothing showing so you're going to get
it really in front of his face and then
if you can't get him and I don't know
the only issues get him to look at the
class with you while you got it look at
the class with me the rest of it will
take care of itself